in searching forever odd Oh Jenifer
Harbury detailed her three years
battling the governments of both
Guatemala and the u.s. to discover the
fate of her kidnapped and murdered
husband a communist guerrilla leader now
she charts the history and consequences
of American involvement in torture in
her new book truth torture and the
American Way she spoke about it recently
for an hour hi I'd like to welcome
everyone to one it to our series of book
signings here at Busboys and poets this
is probably the third or fourth and
we're learning our way through these
things I want to thank everyone for
being here I know it's been a big
weekend for many people so people are
exhausted so they're going to probably
be coming trickling and as we move along
but I had the chance to meet Jennifer
Harbor a while back and had had also the
chance to get involved in what she's
doing right now
here in Capitol Hill and at the holiday
at the Holiday Inn in Capitol Hill which
was in mock trial of Rumsfeld Tennant
and Gonzales and I was involved in it in
more than one way I was a witness in the
in the play that she did which I think
by the end they were convicted as being
guilty so I think as as deserved so and
her book her new book and and she'll
tell you more about the conference that
was going on here at the Holiday Inn
Capitol Hill which was a anti-torture
conference
she has an organization called stop
which is stopping torture permanently is
the name of the organization that she
runs an organization that is looking
into allegations of torture all over the
world by the United States in particular
and I think a lot of this stuff has come
up since they have a rape situation in
Guantanamo Bay for most of us the word
torture in America don't seem to you
know go hand in hand you think of
America as being the the land of freedom
and opportunity and the land of
of human rights and civil rights and so
on we all think surprised and shocked to
some level that we saw what happened a
ballet but these types of things have
been going on for many many years and
they're certainly very familiar to
Jennifer Harbury
I'll let her tell you the story that she
has and her new book toward truth
torture in the American Way I think she
should go a very long way in explaining
some of those things that we've been
hearing about for so long so I'd like to
introduce Jennifer Harbury thank you
thank you I'd like to especially thank
Andy Shallal and Busboys and poets for
providing such an amazing venue and the
most amazing array of books I've seen in
a very long time I want to especially
thank Andy also for participating in the
Unitarian Universalist Service Committee
stop campaign and our Interfaith
coalition's formal mock trial on Sunday
on we did get relatively rowdy I would
say but it was it was a great trial it
was non-fictional in that although we of
course had to use actors for certain
roles it was based on real the United
States laws real UN and international
treaty standards the information we
presented was in fact taken from
credible sources either US government
documents Washington Post articles New
York Times Direct detainee statements
etc etc we also brought in living
torture survivors from Latin America who
had had exactly the same practices used
on them and often had a North American
in their cell and finished up with a
statement from a military expert that we
need not be doing those torture doesn't
work as an intelligence tool and in fact
it endangers us instead of increasing
our national security so thank you very
much Andy he played a really remarkable
role and we're very grateful the reason
I wrote this book is because I wanted to
put together all of the information I've
been amassing over the last many years
about u.s. sponsored torture and
ironically I had almost finished this
book when the Abu Ghraib photographs in
fact you know era done on 60 minutes
which of course made me have to go back
to the drawing board and rewrite it
I was I was happy to rewrite it given
the incredible moral crisis that I think
our country is facing now certainly
torture has been declared abhorrent to
all of our national values since the
framing of the Constitution when the
question came up with our Congress very
early on after the American Revolution
as to whether or not torture should be
permitted here in special instances of
national security
Patrick Henry pointed out that the rack
the screw in the star chamber were left
behind in the old world for very good
reason and that if we allow those
practices here we are quote lost and
undone needless to say we are very often
failed to live up to our national values
slavery being a very obvious example the
internment of the Japanese police
brutality cases condoning of lynchings
the Trail of Tears for Native Americans
right up through today with the case of
Abner Louima certainly Rodney King
prison conditions and so on and so forth
but what I'd really like to talk about
tonight is not only what's happening in
Iraq Afghanistan and Guantanamo but how
far back that practice goes what those
what the legal consequences of that fact
is and what we need to do about it and
that is what the book is about I've
compiled all of the cases that I've
encountered during my investigations in
Latin America during the last decade
I've also done a legal analysis and also
interviewed many security experts so
that is the content of the book I think
most of you know part of my personal
history my husband was a Mayan
resistance leader in Guatemala in the
1990s he was captured alive by the
Guatemalan military who declared that he
had been killed in combat that was false
they had in fact taken him as a prisoner
held him in secret detention and decided
to subject him to long term torture in
order to break him psychologically they
didn't want anyone interfering on the
basis of human rights so they killed an
18 year old soldier whom they literally
dragged out of the base the same night
battered to death so that he was
unrecognizable placed him in an all
agree olive-green uniform and put him in
a grave when we asked what the
description
of the body was we were sent my
husband's description instead of the 18
year olds um my much later found out
that in fact ever ARLA was alive being
tortured opened the grave and began a
series of hunger strikes to save his
life
throughout the entire two years I was
trying to find him he was in fact alive
for most of that but it was only after
my third hunger strike in in the spring
of 1995 that we were able to get
information from a very furious
congressman torricelli who was on the
House Intelligence Committee and they
were able to confirm that ever Darlow
had in fact been tortured for a very
long time period he had in fact been
killed upon orders of Colonel Julio
Roberto Alvarez who was also working for
the CIA as a paid informant or asset we
also learned that the same month that al
Perez was witnessed bending over the
torture table with my husband's body so
grotesquely swollen that one arm and leg
had apparently hemorrhaged that outfit
has received $44,000 from the CIA that
same month we also learned that several
of the people in military intelligence
were in fact paid CIA assets that were
handling my husband's case many of them
were also on the corrupt officer list of
the DEA then between eight and twelve
were trained at the School of the
Americas all roads in the end do lead to
Rome during that time period I became
fast friends with sister Diana Ortiz who
of course was very seriously tortured in
Guatemala and had a North American come
into her cell and demand that she be
released to him he knew where she would
be
he knew what her name was he knew on a
first-name basis who the tortures were
and had the authority to demand that she
be released because she was an American
citizen he spoke heavily accented
Spanish yeah with a very heavy American
accent and looked not at all Aguada
Malin and understood her perfectly when
she addressed him in English and
eventually responded to her in English
when she later asked that the US
Embassy's send this man back to release
the other people or rescue the other
people in that clandestine center that
torture Center the smear campaign was
started by the United States government
to the effect that
she was perhaps mentally unstable didn't
know what had happened rumors began to
circulate about self-inflicted injuries
such as the 111 Sigrid and eleven
cigarette burns on her back and so on
and so forth it was very clear to all of
us who knew sister Deanna who now runs
of course the torture abolition and
survivors support coalition that she
knew exactly what had happened to her
so I began investigating more and more
cases of us sponsorship of torture
whether direct or by proxy I was just
very curious because certainly it was
unlawful to heavily fund and also train
well known human rights violators across
Latin America under our different
statutes for the appropriations bill it
was illegal to fund known in systematic
human rights violators
but what cut the CIA in the State
Department had always Bement Lea
insisted was that there was no direct
participation in the dust squad torture
maybe they weren't really members of the
military anyway maybe they were private
operators and in any event the CIA CIA
and the School of the Americas were just
trying to professionalize people and
make the situation better and knew
nothing about individual cases as it
turned out in my husband's case on the
CIA and the State Department knew where
he was and that he was still alive
during the two years that I was trying
to find him by the time the truth came
out he had either been thrown from a
helicopter or dismembered it also spent
a very long period of time in a full
body cast because he had tried so many
times to escape the decision to kill him
came only after they insisted that he
lead them to a clandestine radio station
and he led them instead into an ambush I
think it's important to take note the
two cases sister Deanna tried to say
anything they told her to say so that
they would stop burning her and
attacking her with ferocious dogs my
husband said nothing at all in two years
on the use of torture as any
intelligence official will tell you does
not give you good intelligence it either
gives you nothing because people know
they're going to die anyway or it gives
you Niagara Falls every name in the
phone book it does not give you good
intelligence our government now with Abu
with the photographs at Abu Ghraib
the ongoing and relentless stream of
disclosures witness statements forensic
reports etc etc has offered us three
statements they say that number one
there's not really a pattern and
practice or any kind of policy of
torture which really at this stage of
the game is ridiculous on its face but
nevertheless only those few soldiers
that have been directly caught on film
or in other unassailable portions of
evidence have been brought to
court-martial and sent to prison and
what our high-level officials keep
saying is it's not a policy it's just a
few soldiers out of control it's
excessive force here and there and those
people have been brought to trial and
put in prison so this is the American
Way don't worry about it it's being
taken care of why do they keep insisting
that in the face of this flood of
evidence that it isn't it is indeed
policy because if it's policy if it was
authorized at the very top then under
the laws of command responsibility
people like mr. Rumsfeld and mr. Tennant
must stand trial for criminal charges as
well there are two felony statutes in
this country which give you a 20 year
sentence for ordering or conspiring to
order or to carry out the torture of a
detainee abroad it's a felony if the
person dies it can carry the death
penalty as well we keep hearing first
that it's not a policy second that it's
not illegal that what's being done in
the case of the detainees because
they're terrorists and enemy combatants
somehow they fall between the laws and
treaties that prohibit torture and I'll
come back to that in a moment and
thirdly they keep telling us that well
even if it's illegal which it's not put
that aside for the moment you have to
let us do it or you will be the next
ones to die in a terrorist attack you
have to let us keep you safe so what
I've done in the book is just trapped
those three issues I've already told you
about my own case and sisters sister
Diana's after I saw the photographs at
Abu Ghraib and also started reading all
of the other reports coming out of
Afghanistan Iraq and Guantanamo it
became very very clear that exactly the
same highly refined intelligence
techniques are being used over and over
and over again waterboarding by the CIA
quote we hold a person
head underwater until they think they're
going to drown sounds kind of like a
pull dunking but in fact you can ask any
Latin American survivor or any Afghan
survivor and they'll tell you the
person's head is held under until they
do drown they go into convulsions and
lose consciousness and have to be given
resuscitation or CPR then they're
drowned again it is clearly a torture
technique beware of sanitize language
people being slammed headfirst into
walls
people like de Lauer who were beaten
across the same portion of his leg over
and over again until according to the
forensic report his leg was Papa fide
quote-unquote as if he had been hit by a
bus keeping people in pits of water so
deep they have to stand on tiptoe to
keep from drowning extreme heat with
extreme cold or in guantánamo chaining a
person hand and feet to the floor with
blasting music strobe lights going on
and on denial of toilet privileges on
and denial of food for up to 24 hours so
that when the FBI people came in and saw
the prisoner the next day one of them a
torn all a hair out of his head and the
rest of them they described as in a
state as if they were jello they had to
be carried back to their rooms precisely
that combination of techniques has been
declared by the United Nations and in
the case of Israel - absolutely
constitute torture the use of ferocious
dogs the use of rats these are all very
specialized techniques in fact if you
remember the iconic photograph of the
hooded man on the box with wires
attached to his hands into his genitals
all intelligence experts in this country
can tell you the name of that position
it's called the Vietnam position because
that's where it originated if you read
back on some of the older cases out of
Vietnam the cold room was used in
Vietnam throwing people out of
helicopters was used in Vietnam
it used to be operation Phoenix now it's
operation Scorpio in Iraq at this time
we're using people on that actually
worked for Saddam Hussein to form a
de-facto death squad which is organized
and supervised now by CIA officials
general ma hush was beaten to death and
suffocated by that Scorpio group in the
presence of a CIA agent so we have the
same pattern of the same types of
torture over and over and over again
the possibility of it just being a
coincidence that did a few kids at Abu
Ghraib or a few out-of-control soldiers
in Bagram at one point on just happen to
think of exactly those techniques is
impossible it cannot be coincidence its
policy those are very refined techniques
and they've been used systemically in
those three areas now since the
beginning of the war on terror but if we
look back further this goes way back if
we look back further all of the cases
that I've looked into in Latin America
Central America and Vietnam the same
things were happening
I've now documented more than 20 cases
and these are in the book of people who
had the same situation as sister Deanna
Ortiz where they were severely tortured
in secret detention with a North
American coming in sometimes advising
sometimes listening sometimes handing
over a list of questions and sometimes
supervising what were the techniques to
which they were subjected sister Deanna
Ortiz was attacked by ferocious dogs and
also filmed incessantly with them
telling her if you ever try to talk
we'll release these films to your
friends in your family for example Ynez
Maria in Honduras was also terrorized by
a dog
she was also subjected to stress and
duress position she was hung by her
hands and feet in what's called the
scorpio position from a hook in the
ceiling until her arms dislocated
she was also waterboarded and there is a
CIA report that confirms that they did
send one of their agents over there to
assist and advise and found her
unconscious near a vat of water but they
suggested that she might have been
asleep actually they weren't sure that
she was unconscious odd they did nothing
to help her be released in all of these
cases that I'm describing that people
went in and out often paid money asked
questions got information are supervised
and then left did they tell a courts
where these kidnap victims were no did
they tell the police no did they tell a
family members of the groups for the
disappeared no we could have saved many
of these lives not just my husband's but
many of these lives we also have cases
where Dan material from the Office of
Public Safety taught electrical shock
treatment and torture throughout Brazil
and
those techniques had never been seen
before his arrival there the case of the
water pit that's being used in
Afghanistan that's in my husband CIA
files what that document literally says
is prisoners are being held in pits of
water so deep they have to hang on to
overhead bars to keep from drowning and
then it says also on after interrogation
sessions they're loaded into small
airplanes after midnight and dead or
alive they're thrown into the ocean to
avoid any discovery later of the torture
techniques to which they had been
subjected again the types of techniques
we just see over and over and over again
exactly the same thing going all the way
back to Vietnam what about the legal
issues we hear again and again that yes
but their enemy combatants so the Geneva
Conventions don't apply let's look at
that and again all of this is in the
book the third Geneva Convention says
you cannot torture a prisoner of war a
prisoner of war is someone who is a
member of a formal army wearing a
uniform well fine obviously a saboteur
that was not in a formal army would then
not be a prisoner of war and not
protected by that clause but what is
never mentioned by our officials is the
Fourth Geneva Convention which applies
to everybody else anyone who is not a
formal military member or ie a civilian
there's of course civilians like women
children orphans in the elderly that are
routinely protected but this particular
provision specifically provides
protections also for an insurgent for
someone who carries out acts of sabotage
or for people who might carry out even
deadly acts of force against the
occupying power does that say that these
people can be left in the streets to
continue to attack our troops well of
course not it says you arrest them put
them in a fair trial and then put them
in prison like anybody else like our
bombers here in Oklahoma precisely you
don't leave them out on the streets you
do treat them humanely those people
specifically under the under the Fourth
Geneva Convention cannot be tortured or
humiliated there's also the Convention
Against Torture which prohibits any kind
of torture humiliation of any person
even during times of war or security
crises for any country
there's our two domestic statutes which
prohibit torture and make them a felony
one is 18 US Code section 23 40 the
other one is the war crimes act of 1996
it's prohibited there are no exceptions
there's never a category of people that
can legally be tortured or abused the
way we are doing every single day now we
literally are forcing our allies to
choose between obeying the requirements
of the Geneva Convention which say they
ought to be arresting us if we cross
into their own jurisdiction or sent
insisting that we arrest our own people
pretty soon there aren't going to be war
crimes trials abroad exactly what we're
trying so hard to avoid because we're
not doing anything about it here many
people ask me if it's a felony why
aren't they on trial well who decides to
give an indictment mr. Ashcroft and mr.
Gonzales mr. Gonzalez wrote the memos we
have a big breakdown now of our system
of checks and balances with the obvious
disastrous results this is exactly what
the founding fathers were trying to
avoid
lastly we are told over and over again
we have to allow torture because it's
the only way that our kids or ourselves
will not be in the next World Trade
Center bombing that's that's a very
scary threat we hear again and again the
ticking bomb situation in fact what we
heard in those radio reports early on
those stories of intelligence officers
who saved the world by torturing a
suspect while a bomb was about to go off
those all turned out to be fictional
they were hypothetical I've asked again
and again it hasn't yet really occurred
on any big scale there have been much
smaller situations for example in Israel
where a small bombing was prevented but
nothing more if there was in fact a huge
nuclear weapon about to go off under
Grand Central Station in New York let's
look at that
because people are afraid and it is an
issue if that were to happen and they
captured a detainee or a suspect what
would happen well if they torture the
person as I've said earlier you'll get
either silence you'll get false
information or you'll get Niagara Falls
there's an Iraqi prisoner who literally
under torture said he admitted that he
was
Saddam Hussein in disguise anything just
to not be tortured anymore fine sister
Diana Ortiz when they held up a
photograph of a woman who looked nothing
like her said it's not me they burned
her so she said it's not me they burned
her again you will probably not get the
information you need out of the detainee
in order to save the world what if the
person does start talking well under any
basic rules of covert operations his
friends and colleagues will by then have
moved a bomb as soon as he's missing if
he's so high-level or she is so high
leveled that she would know where such a
where such a bomb was located the chance
of it still being there is about zero
supposing though hypothetically that the
world is saved do we need to change our
laws to allow torture no we don't we
don't need to change them because it
already provides for a situation like
that it's up to the prosecutor to decide
to prosecute I don't think it would
happen if the person really saved the
world from a nuclear explosion if he was
prosecuted the judge would apt a
sentence I would say ten minutes of
community service would be likely
presidential pardon if a sentence were
actually mandatory it's not going to
happen
police and law enforcement officers and
intelligence officials know that but
what is good what's healthy for them to
know is if they use torture they better
be ready to defend themselves absolutely
for assault and murder charges in a
court of law and they better have really
good evidence to justify what they've
done does the shock and awe technique
that we've been using the torture
techniques the excessive force the
blasting down doors the terrorizing of
children in Iraq Afghanistan and and of
course of the prisoners now in
Guantanamo does it make us safer overall
does that big strong he-man image make
us safer or less safe if you look
historically at any of the examples when
those kinds of techniques have been used
in order to quell an uprising it has
never worked the French were thrown out
of Algeria for a while the bombings
became lower when the French used such
terrifying methods and such blanket
torture the people were really
terrorized within Algeria but then the
rage began
they bonded together and through the
French out Mandela became president of
South Africa apartheid no longer exists
there we did not win the war in Vietnam
Northern Ireland in several centuries
has not become more peaceful it doesn't
work I've been very intrigued going back
and forth to Israel Palestine over the
last six or seven months just trying to
get information there about what the
results have been of the very serious on
tactics used there because I think
that's one country where there is a very
serious threat of bombings over and over
again the landau Commission originally
in Israel had declared that if there was
a risk of an imminent attack or an
imminent bombing they could use moderate
force by on 1999 their own civil rights
groups like B'Tselem came to court with
evidence that something like 90% of the
detainees were being tortured in fact
and the court reversed its decision in
Israel and said given that this is
obviously not controllable from now on
you can bring that information in that
you thought there is going to be an
attack as some sort of defensive thing
but it's illegal there is no longer any
exception in their exact statement was
it maybe that a democracy must fight
with one hand tied behind its back but
at least it is the upper hand now of
course we have the problem of
enforcement but it's really good for us
to remember you take that cork out of
the bottle and allow torture in a small
situation and it's uncontrollable it
explodes into general usage for example
does it have to be a nuclear bomb under
grants dental station or just a big one
how big does it have to be does it have
to be a bombing in an hour or tomorrow
this month or just something that might
happen you know when his torture kind of
permissible in terms of a time frame is
it okay if we have the detainee if he or
she won't talk could we pick up his
colleagues and torture them in front of
him how about his wife how about his
children how about the neighbor down the
street that might have seen anything
what happens is that we what already has
happened we start using torture is a
routine way of trying to get
intelligence even though we've been told
again and again and again and seeing
again and again that it doesn't work but
most intelligence people say or experts
say is that people use torture because
they've already failed in their
intelligence gathering job and that
they're frustrated and punishing the
person or trying to terrorize the
community one of those two and I think
that what we've seen in Iraq really goes
to prove that started with flowers being
thrown to the Troops now what's being
thrown is bombs spreading the seeds of
hatred throughout the world against us
that's not going to make us safer
throwing away the Geneva Conventions as
most military people will tell you most
people in the Army are outraged by
what's happening and really fought
behind closed doors for a very long time
to try to prevent these things from
going through and what they'll all tell
you is number one it disgraces us you
know thanks a lot number two it totally
in dangers us it creates this rage
against us so that we're facing more
bombs than ever before especially our
young servicemen and women who are out
there you know on the front lines but
also if any of them are captured how
many people here would stand to see one
of our own soldiers waterboarded hung
from his or her arms and feet until they
turn black would we let that happen to
any of our soldiers no but we've
declared it legal this is a problem this
is a huge problem for our own troops and
the next time people say support our
troops I think we need to remember that
and then of course lastly it endangers
all of us the more rage and hatred
against Americans and the more they see
us as taxpayers and voters not putting
it into it the higher a chance there is
that there will be another attack we're
creating the conditions for that so I'm
just asking everyone to take a look at
the book I put everything in it that
I've learned about during the last 15
years of my life it's the biggest
toolbox I could put together I certainly
invite everyone to join our coalition to
stop torture at the Unitarian
Universalist service committee and with
our interfaith coalition let's work
together and thank you very much
[Applause]
does anyone have any questions there's a
microphone here if you have a question
please come up to the microphone for the
sake of c-span and thank you very much
for your work I have two kinds of
questions one is I'm not clear about
your recommendations or what you're
trying to do other than expose the
horror I didn't have a chance to
thoroughly read your book until now my
other question is I am trying to work
for Kucinich is Department of Peace and
do you think a collaboration with that
would help or would that muddy the
waters in terms of too many issues
getting together what which issue have
casino chests excuse me the Department
of Peace to find create a Department of
Peace as a u.s. cabinet department there
is a bill HR whatever I forget the
number it was introduced last week or so
yes that's very interesting I'd like to
read the bill yes and I think the first
thing we have to do is so many people
are outraged by the use of torture
including many Republicans in fact
across the United States who have said
to me look I voted for Bush I didn't
vote for that what do you want me to do
I think we have to form a much broader
and more flexible coalition and get
everyone to go to our elected
representatives many of whom want to do
something about torture in the Patriot
Act but they don't want to get kicked
out of office for being soft on terror
we need to get our voices much more
unified much more massive and get to the
hill if you watch our websites or
amnesties or any of these groups torture
abolition and survivor Center we have
urgent actions up constantly we're
certainly going to be very concerned
about official you know specific
officials being nominated who have in
our eyes supported torture that would it
ought to be declared illegal and the
always has been illegal you know please
watch our websites and join our
coalition the first step is going to be
with Congress we'll probably do a lot
more actions in the future as well but
the first thing make ourselves heard but
in a very unified
organized fashion with a uniform message
yeah yeah I'm Malachy kilbride I'm with
the DC anti-war Network and I'm also
affiliated with Northern Virginia ng's
for peace and Arlington ian's for peace
Arlington ian's for peace about two
years ago organized a protest outside of
CACI
in Arlington Virginia where they have
their headquarters we know that Donald
Rumsfeld has signed off on certain
procedures to extract information from
those who are held captive
we know that Alberto Gonzales has
written about how it is okay to use
certain methods to extract information
from captives we know that low-level
military personnel have abused and
tortured people held captive in the
middle there are people who work for
companies like CACI and Titan and I read
the news and I don't hear anything about
these people there's like this big black
hole people involved in Abu Ghraib in
Guantanamo
we don't hear anything about them how
can we find out if people working for
these companies are involved in torture
what can we do as citizens to find out
um for certain there's already at least
one or two prosecutions on of people who
work for some of these corporations and
by the way almost all of the people in
groups like Casey and stuff were once
part of Special Ops or were once in not
military intelligence in one way or
another they're very highly trained
military people they make much more
money in a group like Casey on there are
a couple of prosecutions going on where
the evidence and information was so
absolute that our government was forced
to bring that prosecution but only once
they were forced on one way to get more
information about that is of course
doing something like what
ACLU is doing the Freedom of Information
Act I would start by asking amnesty in
the ACLU if they have files on those
specific things and you just gave me the
idea that we should post some of our
information on our website as well on
using groups like KC on sending people
to Egypt or Syria to be tortured they
keep offering that as if somehow if
someone else does it for us they're no
longer legally responsible that's false
if I hire someone to shoot my husband
because I want the insurance money I go
to prison for murder um and if you read
the members there's all sorts of
distortions of that saying you have to
have specific intent for in the example
they give us a case where a homeless
person robs a bank because he wants to
be arrested and put back in jail because
he has a safe place to sleep then so he
stands there with the money until he's
really well if you stretch that to say
that hiring someone else to do the
torture for you gets you off the hook
then a man that hires someone to shoot
his wife for the insurance money
can just say it wasn't me all I wanted
was the insurance I didn't care if she
was dead or not I mean that's a clear
Distortion I'm also under any common
rules of conspiracy for example when we
actually when we sent Maher error to
Syria to be tortured we didn't send him
to Canada where he had a business a wife
children etc etc and we're heedless he
was 17 we sent him to Syria it was our
request not the Syrians who requested
for him to be sent there he was
interrogated about possible al-qaeda
things nothing about his former life in
Syria on we in most of the cases
according to news weeks of these
renditions were flying prisoners over in
our own planes at our own expense
we're often providing a list of
questions sometimes the CIA person is
there looking through a two-way mirror
on in quote the the pipelines to these
different police that groups are well
lubricated with US dollars that more
than takes care of conspiracy law in the
United States more than and under the
conspiracy rules that would make someone
liable under both the federal War Crimes
Act and also 2340 it doesn't get you off
the hook at all
so there's a few prosecutions
the same as with what happened at Abu
Ghraib where the young soldiers were
saying look we were ordered to do this
by the CIA and other intelligence
officials that were here the army
investigators then went and looked at
the role books or the log books and
found that the intelligence people had
signed in under names like Special Agent
James Bond and Special Agent John Doe
when they asked the CIA to release their
files for purposes of a US government
investigation the CIA said no we'll do
our own investigation and they still
have handed over nothing so what's
happening is the soldiers are going to
prison which they should under the basic
rules of conduct right if a soldier is
given an illegal order they're supposed
to refuse to obey that's asking a lot of
someone that young straight out of boot
camp but it is the law and probably
should be but for them to go alone to
prison well the people who ordered it at
the top do not rumsfeld did sign many
authorizations for certain techniques
those were rescinded later but he still
made it cleared it on a case-by-case
basis he could authorize those very
techniques he was rescinding so not
surprisingly it all continued um simply
authorizing it or paying forward all of
that again that doesn't get you off the
hook
it's command responsibility just as in
World War two afterwards at the
Nuremberg trials not just the people who
man the gates at Auschwitz went to
prison he went all the way to the top
it's the intellectual authors as long as
those intellectual authors and people
who give the orders and authorized and
condone the policies as long as nothing
happens to them and they have full and
punitive then the tortures are going to
continue and I'd point out that for me
and sister Diana Ortiz we were told
after the investigation that it was
rogue operators bad apples
they'd been fired from the CIA there was
a huge investigation going on and it
would never happen again it was just one
of those flukes now I found all these
other cases going all the way back to
Vietnam and we're seeing exactly the
same techniques and exactly the same
excuses on national television for the
Middle East note so we really need to
bring this to an end and make sure that
just once there's justice for the
highest level officials
[Applause]
my name is Francis and I was marching
and lobbying today and yesterday for
code pink and progressive Democrats of
America and while all of the street heat
on Saturday and yesterday during all the
civil disobedience actions was very
helpful within the Capitol to make a
point you know this is the outside
strategy this is the inside strategy you
know we want to move you forward towards
a you know a stance where you can say we
need to end the occupation of Iraq and
we need to put a timetable for that that
and we certainly found no one who
defended the use of torture but I have
to ask in all honesty is it really
possible to end the use of torture in
Iraq without ending the occupation of
Iraq and that's where you know a
coalition to fight against torture and
the use of torture may be difficult to
bridge because if people are saying well
we need to extend the occupation in Iraq
but we need to just stop torturing
people there the reality of it is is is
it really possible to do that at this
point or ever I think and again I'm
voicing my own opinion here but it's
based on certain certainly on history
but also on what our own intelligence
experts are telling us I think we cannot
finish the occupation of Iraq unless we
first and foremost stop the torture the
conditions that are needed are being
destroyed by the way that we're carrying
out human rights abuses on such an
enormous scale and again you know just
think at the beginning although there is
huge guilt and culpability on the part
of the United States government for not
having a rebuilding or a reconstruction
plan you know leaving the Iraqi people
without medicine without water etc etc
that was a huge problem but even then
there were flowers being thrown by
carrying out the torture for this huge
period of time we've created rage and
turmoil and trauma which creates a
vicious
we have to stop the torture immediately
and I of course believe having grown up
in the area of Vietnam and marched here
back in the 70s against that word that
we should withdraw right now that's my
opinion it can only get much much worse
but we've created the worst possible
conditions by our use of torture we have
not gained good intelligence Osama bin
Laden is still free and we have only
created conditions that are going to
make it much harder to do what we need
to do I thank you very much for your
important work I just wanted to mention
two conferences addressing that last
month the American Psychological
Association met in Washington DC and we
came up with a statement which we
revived one from 1986 saying that
there's no way no how under no
circumstances is it permissible and it's
also recognized as a completely
unreliable way to get information and my
division 48 the Society for the study of
peace conflict and violence was very
instrumental in working on this
statement Nikki um and in 1999 I was at
a groundbreaking conference in Ramallah
on caring for victims of torture with
Israeli and Palestinian psychologists
doctors British also international and
they said was also definitely against
any kind of medical ethical code and I
see no physicians for Human Rights and
that doctors were not allowed to
participate like in taking physiological
measurements or if they did that they
were considered participating in the
torture thank you very much yeah it is
very disturbing to hear how much
different members of the medical
profession have been assisting and that
really rings especially hard for me
because during most of my husband's
torture sessions a physician was present
to make sure he didn't accidentally die
his intelligence information was of such
value they wanted him to stay alive for
several years and he didn't I mean it's
just a huge abuse of of medical
professionals
are there any other questions
I've been really surprised that there
hasn't been more emphasis put on the
United States joining the International
Criminal Court and I'm wondering uh
because I know nothing about uh laws but
uh they're not being followed anyway
yeah it doesn't matter
no I if a future president were to join
the courts uh what uh would all of these
people be could they be prosecuted under
by this by an International Criminal
Court or is there any way of prosecuting
them even if we're not members
um as you know Italy has already brought
indictments against a number of unnamed
CIA agents for kidnapping someone from
the streets of Milan and sending it to
another country where it was severely
tortured Sweden and Germany are carrying
out very similar investigations of
exactly the same thing um we are not
subjected or we have actually President
Clinton at the very end of his term did
try to sign us into the International
Criminal Court only tab where she raised
it and when he came into office the
legality of that by the way is extremely
questionable but that's what's happened
we are subject automatically as UN
members to the world Court but when
Nicaragua brought us to trial for
bombing fur mining their harbors
illegally under the Sandinistas
government we laughed we thought that
was funny and and didn't do anything
about it on there is of course the
inter-american Court on human rights of
the OAS where I won a lawsuit a civil
lawsuit against the Guatemalan army for
what they did to my husband but the
United States will not subject
themselves to the jurisdiction of that
Court either and in fact we've our
government has been on trying to
pressure many many different countries
into signing what they call a bilateral
agreements in which they agree they
won't ever try to bring international
criminal cases against any US personnel
for violation of Human Rights
anywhere in the world or all of their
aid all of their economic aid will be
cut which of course would be disasters
in many countries some countries are
standing up to us and refusing to sign
but many have already signed
so what we're asking for is for the
United States claiming to be moral
leader of the world to also be above the
law and carry out systemic torture and
violation of all international treaties
and our own domestic law and everyone's
supposed to look the other way we can't
do it it's going to smash our alliances
it's a matter of time before someone
brings Pinochet style charges against us
in one of the European courts because it
has to be done if we expect others to
give us full and punitive a matter of
courage we're asking them to become
aiders and abetters it can't be done
Mairead Maguire was talking at our trial
the other day and saying literally wake
up America you have got to do something
about this do you know what you look
like from overseas and we do could you
give us your website please I my website
the Unitarian website is WWE Unitarian
Universalist Service Committee org
there's a big red stop sign with the Abu
Ghraib figure in the middle witches
needless to say the stop torture
campaign we are working in a coalition
with many other groups and we'll have
links and everything on that as well we
have a reading list most of it right now
is information about the trial but we'll
be updating that I believe the trial was
videoed completely and I think that
video all six hours of it is already
online if you'd like to see it again we
didn't fictionalize anything we used
credible reports real laws and real
attorneys and many real survivors you
mentioned Jennifer that that a lot of
the torture techniques have been used
since Vietnam such as the Vietnam
position that became so famous and is
they actually the mark of your
organization has anyone been indicted
from Vietnam from the Vietnam time for
the use of torture
any any of the any of the US service
than element um for the maligned
massacre eventually people were indicted
but I believe that sergeant was pardoned
eventually so no there really has not
that wasn't torture for sadly exactly it
was bullets um
I don't believe that there has ever been
an intelligence person brought up on
charges of torture and that's partly
because the CIA can keep everything
classified they can conceal all of the
information that would lead to a proper
indictment a trial for example in Italy
to date on just by saying it's national
security or in my husband's case they
can simply block all of those files or
at least they have people on the
intelligence committees in the house in
the Senate are supposed to be
supervising the CIA they all asked about
my husband in that two year period of
time and got nothing he was alive for
most of that so we're 350 other
prisoners who also ended up dead it's a
big problem they have become a nation of
their own they're a complete rogue
agency and they're out of control the
problem is they're acting in our names
with our tax dollars and we are
responsible
today yeah
give us something specific to do when we
leave here on a very straightforward
thing um we've been if you could in your
home communities start joining our first
Monday of the month massive telephone
campaign to your congressperson and
Senator this is very pardon
um what isn't I'm sorry I'm blocking I'm
blanking out on her name but there is a
congresswoman here thank you um call
anyway call people in the Appropriations
Committee on call Senator Leahy give him
your full support and Senator Dodd
they're doing wonderful work support
call senator Levin's office support all
of the bills that are going through in
the house there are two bills one by
congressman Markey and another one by a
congressman Waxman all of those bills
that are going through that are trying
to stop torture call them call them
anyway tell them you're from Washington
DC and you're calling to protest the use
of torture there are speaking points on
our website as well like I say we're
going to be changing all of those also
if you can help us organize on like
local public speaking events or special
public education events you can use any
part of the trial that's on our website
you can use the materials on our website
start getting people to understand all
of these issues like the security issues
we went through today you know you're
welcome to use any portions of the book
obviously that's what I wrote it for but
just start getting the word out so that
everybody starts massively calling and
writing we will be doing and planning
more activities and it would be great if
you would attend those if you don't have
a direct vote through your
congressperson go to the people who are
in charge of certain kinds of
legislation we'll have on our website
also different types of actions that we
need to block or put a stop to and we
would ask you to do that as well our
first step is going to be public
education taking a trial back to the
grassroots because we need the
grassroots very badly and then we will
be carry on more activities here as well
we'll probably be trying to work out
some legal issues very very soon and
we'll have those on our website as well
really curious about the psychology of
the terror I'm much of what you spoke
about tonight seems really almost
unimaginable that human beings would do
this to each other and so I'm wondering
what your what your research was there
the psychology that perpetuates this
kind of barbarism and torture it's very
interesting there's no absolute answer
to that that I found I mean certainly
some torturers are what you'd expect a
born psychopath that finds his or her
right niche on life most though are
simply forced into it as in Guatemala
there were many foot soldiers that were
simply young Mayan kids that were
dragged off the soccer field battered
forced to speak Spanish and then told
participate or join the victim on those
people who had a terrible time after the
war ended that sort of mental barrier
would come down and many of them have
just been a terrible shape ever since um
that's extremely common there are those
people whose walls don't come down I'd
point out that in Guatemala for example
on the number of women who are being
raped and very severely mutilated as in
the death squad era is ten times higher
than Juarez people developed very bad
appetites during the war and it has not
been fixed it's not been put back in
order on how does it all start I think
certainly what one Mossad agent said is
you know if you have to get down to this
kind of activity
you know humiliating the person
outraging the person driving the person
crazy with cane you're not going to get
good intelligence you're just frustrated
because you've failed you know what you
need to use is other types of techniques
and certainly the police and FBI in our
country have been saying look we've
always been able to do it much better
with rapport good cop bad cop
careful investigations examining the
person over and over again and catching
them in errors or lies on stealth if
need be on incentives and disincentives
but not tortured that that sent Abner
Louima to the hospital but it doesn't
get good information
um I think it's also just human nature
when we're frightened and I think the
national reaction to what happened in
New York City was terror
the problem is when were terrified that
it's appealing to carry a great big
stick and seem much more brutal and much
more scary than the other guy I mean
it's sort of comforting I think deep
down inside and I think we sort of have
fallen into hoping that maybe that will
work and keep us safe because we can't
think we'll think of what else will but
I think that's the challenge to all of
us as a society it's like let's figure
out something else that's ridiculous
Jennifer if you would be kind enough to
head over to Busboys and poets books and
do some signing for us that would be
wonderful thank you and if everybody
would join me and a thank you for
Jennifer
Harbury is author of searching forever
otto and bridge of courage
her latest truth torture and the
American Way the history and
consequences of u.s. involvement in
torture is published by beacon press on
the web at beacon org